there's a japanese russian arms heiress
i think it's very important to have fun
and her rival a socialite
ready to steal the crown i feel like
crazy attracts crazy
a male model ready to take his shirt off
at a moment's notice thank you jesus
his friend and confidant there to keep
him in check just go shopping that's the
best therapy
and two women on the hunt for love one
in a rocky relationship
i'm so tired of other people's judgment
the other searching for a man she once
called
dad sometimes i wonder like where is my
real dad
now put them all together throw in
millions
or maybe billions of dollars this is
perfect for hiking add a dash of drama
if you cross her line this is gonna cut
you [ __ ]
and a ton of bling and you've got our
latest breakout reality obsession
ling empire there ain't no dick that
good
coming up interviews with the entire
cast who break down their first season
answering those burning questions what
is the status of your relationship right
now
i don't regret anything regrets the one
thing you can never take away
and revealing behind the scenes secrets
there's a lot more to it
all this and more coming up on behind
the bling e.t
and the cast of bling empire
hello everyone i'm rye sander and we are
kicking things off
with the cast themselves anna christine
kane kevin kelly and kim
here's what they had to say about their
epic first season
and their hopes for a season two take a
look
okay kane kevin reality tv's new dynamic
duo are you ready for your lives to
change with this tv show
so already i'm over with 2020 and like
i'm super excited for 2021
the asians are here i'm gonna start just
by calling you
queen christine reality tv
icon why did you want to uh add reality
tv to your already
very very interesting life
well you know it um it's not necessarily
the reality tv part that was exciting
it's the movement towards cultural
diversity that
is playing out on both cinematic arts
and and television arts um
and i'm really honored to be included in
this project
to progress positively in that direction
kane you seem to kind of be the
connector for everybody the person that
everyone in this group knows so can you
explain to me how this show came
together
and how this friend group came together
so i'm sure you're familiar with like
the
movie crazy rich asians right so after
that home movie came out there was a
huge
um you know demanding asia especially to
find out
to know like who these people are who
are these real
families you know instead of watching a
movie they want to know who these
family are in asia so you know i was
obviously one of them that they
sort of face the book on so there's
through it because of this demand my
friend kelly and i were like oh my god
like let's
do something together and we had this
idea to do like a reality show together
and then slowly but surely like you know
the whole cast kind of came together
and you know i've known christine for
like you know
um five six years kelly for like seven
years
actually kevin's the newest person i you
know that you know i've got to know
so yeah yeah and kelly introduced me to
kane because i was moving at los angeles
and kelly found me on social media
and then i met kane for the first time
and i remember you know i'm like i am
not going to get along with this guy
and then we just hit it off i know it's
crazy we come from such different
backgrounds but like yet like
i don't know just something light about
kevin that you know that
we you know we click on are you single
here
am i single yet blast her
out you're putting more diamonds in her
treasure what do you hope the viewers
walk away
from season one of bling empire feeling
and thinking
i'm hoping that the audiences will
resonate with our personal stories and
journeys that we
really shared so authentically and in
really raw form
the struggles that affect both wealthy
and not
and the triumphs that we have
experienced as well
and we hope that that will inspire
strength and those who might be facing
the same challenges
we all have we all go through the same
problems like a lot of people
to me you know and it's it's way
deeper than all the blings
you really lay it all out there when it
comes to your family stuff
on the show i want to know what your
in-laws think about you doing bling
empire
okay well the in-laws that's um i think
that's a that's a tricky situation from
for any any person um whether asian or
not
and i'd like to think it's particularly
trickier
with an eastern cultural background just
because of
the generations of expectations and
pressures
um i don't know how they feel
i hope they do not watch the show and
i'm secretly i'm trying to figure out if
they have netflix
because i i i think that it's still a
very
touchy subject um and it would be for
any family to be
discussed on a global platform
so for that i'm very sorry in-laws
i'll produce another son for you i
promise
kane how does your family feel about you
opening up
this kind of private world oh my gosh i
just spoke to my dad yesterday and i was
like dad i have to
you know i apologize if i'm putting my
health my family out there
you know but he knows netflix he knows
it's such a big platform and you know
he's like you could do use this platform
and
have so many other opportunities you
know be it with your work or like
helping people raising awareness
so i mean they didn't say they're proud
but i feel like
you know um maybe inside they might be a
little
so we'll see looking back at season one
any regrets
kim maybe the drink throw what drink
i feel like crazy attracts crazy do i
regret that
absolutely not at that moment
at that moment no and i like i was like
did i get it on the oh well
i mean i did not go into this show
thinking
a penis pump would be at the center of
drama
tell me about it
she has a penis pump why does she have a
penis pump
in their shower
oh that's somebody's juice i throw it
outside outside
[Music]
oh my god that's a penis pump
this is this is not a screw you
situation this is a
cute situation the penis pump
the into this the infamous penis pump
can you give the people an answer why
was that in your shower
yes
venus was in the guest bathroom show
okay not in yours so it wasn't yours
no but it was embarrassing to
my guest is this a guest we know
no no okay so i didn't expect
people to walk around my house if i were
a producer
right now how could i see my place on
music no
so you gotta go with flow it was there
they found it right or wrong it doesn't
matter
it's done it's there it makes for good
tv
i don't think so oh what really
if the show does come back for another
uh
year what would you want to see the
group take on in a season two
are you kidding it's taking me so long
to do instagram
i've never watched a reality show
so i'm just going with the flow they
tell me
or what the scene tells me i just i just
am okay it's hard to plan these things
if some
something happens you just have to kind
of go with
what i think i'd love to go to south
korea
i'd love to go to south korea with
everybody not just to
be like oh where my parents at you know
you my dad you might you know
but like i think it'd be a good cultural
experience because i think kane always
pushes me to be more korean
you're too white you're white no i think
it's good for you kevin i personally
bryce i think traveling is going to be a
huge thing
i would actually like to fly the whole
cast to
singapore um and you know showcase like
show them
um what singapore truly is so definitely
for season two i would
love that i would love to see can't find
love and i would love to see heaven find
love on season two as well
why are we laughing you guys should be
bracing for impact the show's out there
the dms i think on both ends are gonna
be flooded what is your message to those
who might be uh
trying to slide in there
because he has a lot of girls right now
signing in
hey kate hey this is my type like if you
hear my type uh you'd
be more than happy to slide in take your
shot
what's your type then oh man i love
well obviously i i'm more gravitated
beauty wise like
towards asian obviously but i've
actually discovered i really like
colombian as well
so that's also my type uh is like
ratchet
he likes the wild ratchet type
i mean as long as they're okay with like
the attention i get i'm totally cool but
yeah they need to be a little ratchet
get down and dirty a little bit once in
a while i definitely
i'm gonna give love a shot because all
my life i've always been
you know this strong independent girl
that's all about
get your career first and love's always
gonna be there but i feel like if i put
all that energy into love
it might work so i'm open to that that's
where i'm at right now so i'm actually
manifesting i'm praying every day i'm
like you know if i can manifest i'm
going to manifest this
right right uh yeah i think yeah the dms
will be flooded
on uh friday saturday sunday and kane
what about you what if people try to get
in your dms oh my god i've been getting
a lot of vm's
regarding like collaborations and stuff
which i'm really excited about
i want free [ __ ] but kane
i meant like the suitors like a love
interest may be sliding in there not a
corporation
oh my gosh brian i'm not focused on that
right now
all right guys anything else you want to
say about bling empire what people
should take away from the show
your favorite moment anything i hope
oh
[Laughter]
i really hope people take away from this
especially the asian community that they
can be proud
in the reality space we have so much in
media and like
movies tv but reality space where are
the asians
so i think it's really especially asian
americans
i think it's going to be something
they'll really be proud of they can
relate to when they get beyond just
the bling and the fashion part of it so
i just hope people enjoy themselves and
just take the show and like just
you know have fun with it
they've sparred all season long dueling
one another
in diamonds anna and christine but who
holds the title
of queen b here's what the fierce
frenemies had to say in response to that
question
and so much more take a look
i'm still going through the process
where i'm learning
who i can and cannot trust if you cross
her line
this is gonna cut you [ __ ] you and anna
is a reality tv feud for the ages
i want to know if um you're aware of all
the kind of cat and mouse game of you
and anna all season long of all the
little tricks she pulled on you
all the little digs you took at her
i'm aware of quite a few of them i think
she enjoys the game playing
and i'm a happy participant what do you
think is at the core of that dynamic
insecurity and security
to anybody i am me and
i not that i'm any better than anybody
that is different but i don't
need to prove anything that's my owner
said
know who you are inside so what is your
hope for that relationship with
christine moving forward
is it a friendship is it this continued
kind of
frenemy place what do you hope happens
next
i wish i could have the right christine
[Laughter]
that was a joke um yes i would like to
be her best friend
no that wasn't i i don't know it is what
it is it will become whatever it is
my hope in moving forward between anna
and i is that we focus our energy
not even on friendship per se but really
on things that
matter more i hope that we'll put the
necklace gate aside
and put our money put our
money towards better causes do you
regret any of those messy moments
there's the yoga invitation the changing
of the
the place cards there's the giving her
the wrong
time to come to one of your events do
you regret any of that or
is it all in good fun i think he's in
good fun i don't regret anything
regret's the one thing you can never
take away right
right he said whatever it's done is done
it's important to always
keep some fun in one's life
any regrets from season one the anal
comment maybe
oh you know i i say it really
in a form of like awe and admiration
i i mean i have to mention i did have
um a s-e-x uh it's a sex
black-tie sex toy a couple years ago at
the chateau marmont penthouse she has a
sex party so she claims
okay unless her younger sex party you
know i give anna
all the credit she deserves for being
you know adventurous in her um
personal life she has a penis pump
why does she have a penis pump in their
shower
and hope i'm hoping that makes her
happier and makes her a happier person
because
she's having happier moments in the
bedroom there ain't no jake
that good who do you think won out in
season one christina
anna hands down no competition not none
at all
none i don't know if christine has a
chance they say hannah
i mean you know anna for me that's my
vote i said
your daddy a weapon weapon what guns i
like i would not mess with anna
yeah don't mess with the adam no her
father sells bombs
guns i think it's very important to have
fun
i like to think that both anna and i
have grown from
those arguments and that we are
both older and wiser i'd like to say
that because she's
older i hope that she would be a little
bit wiser than me
um and i do have a lot to learn
of course do you have a favorite jab you
you tossed her away this seat first
season
no i mean if anything if it looks like i
did
it wasn't meant to be just it kind of
like at that moment
but um perhaps next season i can think
of one
there you go that would be great
[Music]
he may have had a crush on kelly all
season long but that didn't stop kevin
from making moves and looking for love
even if his new love interest throws a
drink in his face
here's what kim and kevin had to say
about their potential new romance
take a look and in the finale can we see
you and kevin may
be thinking about something i think
you're a great person
yeah i think we've got great
what is this vibes
you got a crush on me i get it the last
moment we had together at that party
i felt a spark but i was like is this
because we're in the moment
like this feels wrong like she hated me
i hated her
can you give me any info of where things
go
after that conversation oh boy kevin
kevin you know kevin and i have such a
um
weird relationship but we get along at
the same time
um he's a very nice guy you know on the
show
i think a lot of people might think like
oh why she's so mean it's just
like you ever have a friend that you can
just say whatever
to and they just kind of like put up
with it well kevin is that friend to me
you know and i love seeing him get mad
sometimes because you know
it's just exciting that's all
right are you giving it a shot is this
an actual
relationship you would consider or is or
is that just fun
i don't know she's a friend now it's
like i i really care about her i don't
want to
just do it because she's feeling
vulnerable and there's a spark i want to
do because it's like
something real i definitely i'm going to
give love a shot
because all my life i've always been
you know this strong independent girl
that's all about
get your career first and love's always
gonna be there but i feel like if i
put all that energy into love
it might work so i'm open to that that's
where i'm at right now
does love mean kevin
you know kevin's got great traits too
but then
i know too much about his dating life so
i don't know
okay
it's the rocky relationship that
everyone
can't stop talking about kelly
and andrew so where do these two stand
today
et's kevin frazier caught up with the
two reality stars who break down their
rocky relationship and
where they see themselves in the future
take a look
i was in my room on the phone with you
having a private moment but we didn't
know it was gonna get like that i didn't
realize you were gonna go
crazy it just went on and on and on and
on you were i was worried
i was worried no you weren't worried
about me worried why can't you look into
my eyes when you get really extreme
you can't calm down i don't know what to
say do you not love me or do you clearly
you two are still together
what is the status of your relationship
right now we're doing better than we've
ever been i
for me i think personally the show was a
very difficult time for us it was one of
the darkest time of our relationship
and um especially with cameras in our
lives was very difficult
um you know so it caught a little it
caught a dark time of our
five years span of our relationship and
for us
after the show wrap we took some time
off and just kind of be our
be with ourselves and work on ourselves
we are committed to each other
and we are you know we are working every
day and we're still working every day
she's the love of my life i knew the
first time when i kissed her
that she was the love of my life she
makes me want to be a better man that's
pretty cliche
but it's true um and i always admit to
my fault where i fall short and do the
work
and i can't wait for the people to see
that you know if we get a season two
so does it make you crazy that you're
doing this work and now all this stuff
from 2018 comes back
up like it's happening today it's been a
blessing
without the therapy in place there's no
way that any of us would have taken this
and i'm not saying that it hasn't been
uh easy it's been rough you know
but i'm also aware of what i need to do
because i was like wow that's how
i was being in moments of feeling
helpless
i i feel so proud of how far we
came you know that was us back then and
now this is us yes
you're way overreacting right now
okay bye
i want to ask you were you fairly
represented in that scene in paris
i'm going to quote kelly because she
asked me that and pushed pause
and i was silent and she's like that was
an unfair edit let's just be real
drew are you okay that was an unfair
edit
i was like it may have been unfair may
have not but
it did what it needed to do it kept
viewers watching
it had someone then to hate it gave a
rest of people to love
and it gave me most importantly a point
of view of
who i was in that moment of losing it
and being out of character and what i
need to do to never lose it again
kelly was it fair unfortunately i feel
like season one didn't really give
a full look of complete look of our
relationship i think it highlighted the
bad part of it
um and you know i'm really hoping season
two we can change that
[Music]
that last shot where you walk into the
house
and andrew opens the door was that a
moment for you andrew where you got to
exhale and you were like
thankfully she's back
even with my faith i was surprised i
thought i lost to love my life so yeah
when i came and opened the door it was a
lot of
uh possum play cool man
you know let's get her inside first you
know
um and i was just blown away she chose
shows chose love i follow my heart kelly
i want you to tell me
who is andrew today compared to that guy
two years ago
who's he today oh my god i'm gonna start
crying
andrew is such a he's loving he's honest
he's faithful um he's a hard worker
man he is hard working he works through
everything he never gives up
i'm just so proud of him um i also have
to ask you
about kids in the future you thought
about that have you had that
conversation
yeah that's one thing we both agree like
i we want to we want to be parents uh
for me i think being a mother is such a
beautiful experience we definitely want
to have kids
three to six a good number i don't know
what three to six maybe like two
i'm like wow three to six we can adopt
them
that's true that's actually very true
andrew i'm gonna give you last word
is there anything you want to say to
people out there
move forward in your life you can't
allow negative things to hold you back
or to push you into the ground you can
never outrun your demons
your demons will always outrun you you
must face them and beat them with
discipline and love
you love that woman man don't you you
love her she means everything to you
doesn't she
yeah that's awesome that's great
that is fantastic that's a wrap on
behind the bling e.t
and the cast of bling empire be sure to
check out season
one of bling empire streaming now on
[Music]
netflix